and it is that right to peaceful protest
that has sparked this entire
sub-conversation that first emerged on
wednesday when drew brees the saints
quarterback future hall of famer a man
who has done more for the city of new
orleans than any football player has
ever done for any city in the history of
the league a man who gave 5 million
dollars to covet 19 relief just a few
months ago along with his wife to help
people in new orleans but when the issue
came up again
of
protesting during the anthem he
reiterated his position from four years
ago that he will never agree i will
never agree with anyone disrespecting
the flag we read the apology that he
posted during the show yesterday it hit
about 8 30 a.m eastern last night he
posted another apology on instagram
here's the second apology from drew
brees
i know there's not much that i can say
that would make things any better right
now
but i just want you to see in my eyes
how sorry i am
for the comments that i made yesterday i
know that it hurt many people
especially
friends teammates
former teammates
loved ones
people that i care and respect deeply
that was never my intention
i wish
i would have laid out what was on my
heart
in regards to the george floyd murder
the mod arbory
the years and years of social injustice
police brutality
and the need for so much
reform and change
in regards to legislation so many other
things
to bring equality to our black
communities
i am sorry
and i will do better
and i will be part of the solution
and i am your ally
and i know no words will do that justice
what we said yesterday big cat
at the time that drew brees hadn't yet
apologized and then once he did in the
form of a written statement the apology
needs to match
the original statements in format
the original statements were given in
the context of an interview a written
statement felt incomplete to me for a
couple of reasons first of all because
it was written
second of all because it didn't address
one key question
the video apology may very well have
been an effort to try to better bridge
that gap between what the initial
statements looked like and sounded like
and what the apology looks like and
sounds like and it came at the end of
the day when brees had a team meeting
shaquille o'neal was part of that he was
previously scheduled to participate he
continued to participate he shared some
information that he gleaned from it but
i still believe two things i think that
there needs to be a drew brees interview
where he faces specific questions about
why he said what he said and what he
truly believes and ultimately he needs
to address the one unanswered question
and i say this in all deference to drew
i have a ton of respect for drew brees
but we have to look at these issues
within the four corners of what has been
put in front of us
and when you say
on wednesday i will never
respect or i will never agree excuse me
with disrespecting the flag and then you
apologize the next day
presumably for that statement
you have to address i think
whether or not you still
believe
the thing you said
that lit the fuse and he hasn't
addressed that yet
that's the one thing that i'm curious
about if i'm curious about it as an
outsider to the new orleans saints
organization i suspect that there are
men within the team
who now maybe they were privy to it
yesterday maybe i don't know why he
would say it during the team meeting
and not say it publicly
if he said during the team meeting it's
okay if you protest he needs to say it
publicly because that's the way to fix
this that's the way to get people to
understand what he's apologizing for
because without saying i've changed my
position to me the apology seems a bit
hollow
yeah
drew brees stated his opinion that's how
he felt when he said when he gave that
interview that is how he feels and i i
think there's a little bit of confusion
online as well where people are saying
well drew brees doesn't have a right to
opinion drew brees can't say what he
wants to say of course he can say what
he wants to say
but he also has to face the fact that it
was incredibly tone deaf and it was
basically i haven't learned anything in
the last four years because he ran the
2016 playbook that a lot of people were
running where they made a peaceful
protest about police brutality to black
america about the flag and disrespecting
troops and that's not what it's about
and that's not what it was about in 2016
it's especially not what it's about
today so for him to come out and and
basically trying to run that same
playbook
he he is now uh showing that he hasn't
listened at all and he hasn't listened
to his teammates he hasn't listened to
the other p other people in the leagues
he hasn't listened to his community
that's where people are upset and i
think everyone has a right to be upset
if if they know drew brees or they're
hurt by drew brees so drew brees has a
right to say whatever he wants here but
when it when his opinion is tone deaf
and it's clear that he hasn't learned
anything and he hasn't learned he hasn't
really listened to what people are
saying
of course he's going to get some
backlash and you said it mike he is
apologizing more for the backlash than
his actual opinion which that's where
you have to shift
people's brains and have them understand
the issue
on a deeper level than just simply flag
eq you know flag equals stand
neil equals disrespect because that's
kind of what the the argument is what
people want to make it and they make it
about that and then it takes away from
everything and it takes away i mean even
the last three days talking about the
drew brees thing is taken away from
what's going on in america which is
unfortunate but it's also a good lesson
that this is where we've come from in in
the last four years think about it this
way mike last four in 2016 what drew
brees said
was pretty much the sentiment of the nfl
and and the and the in the play that
everyone ran to kind of quiet the
protest down what drewbry says in 2020
it's r it's met with a lot of
disappointment and a lot of uh backlash
online and i think that's a good thing i
know people will bring up cancel culture
drew brees still is this the quarterback
for the saints he hasn't been canceled
in terms of his job his you know the
millions of dollars he's met drew brees
had a bad opinion and he was called out
on it and that's good that's a progress
that that that means that people are
starting to listen and understand this
issue at a deeper level and know that
when someone says oh well i don't want
to disrespect the flag they're way off
because it's not about the flag and it
hasn't been about the flag
and this is an important point i almost
said it's an important nuance but
there's no nuance to this this isn't a
situation where drew brees in the heat
of the moment used inappropriate
language or made an off-colored joke or
said something into a hot mic that he
wouldn't have said if he knew people
were listening he deliberately
intentionally and in calculated fashion
shared his opinion shared his belief the
backlash was to his belief
so
what are you apologizing for
if you still cling to that belief so
part of the apology has to be true it
has to be
i no longer believe that it's
disrespectful to the flag to the nation
to the military to engage in peaceful
protest by kneeling during the national
anthem and again if he said that
within the privacy of the team meeting
that occurred yesterday if that was part
of what induced his teammates to accept
his apology
he needs to say it publicly and if he's
not willing to say it publicly big cat
my concern is that drew is trying to not
piss off anyone he's trying to make
everyone happy and with this issue
you're not going to make everyone happy
you've got to pick a side either you say
that kneeling during the national anthem
is a peaceful protest that is within the
rights of every american
whether or not you would do it yourself
you acknowledge and support their right
to do it or you say i will never agree
with anyone disrespecting the flag you
can't be in both camps you can't have a
foot in each position it's one or the
other so i don't know what he said to
get his teammates to accept his apology
but if i'm his teammate and i'm offended
by his opinion and he says anything
other than i've changed my view
i'm not accepting his apology
and yeah if he's saying it privately and
not publicly i'm wondering why isn't he
coming out and saying
i have changed my view and and look i'm
not trying to be
unfair to drew here i'm trying to be
fair to the story there is a gap
that hasn't been addressed yet that
needs to be addressed before we can
fully understand exactly what he's
apologizing for and whether this apology
is simply uh oh
i stepped right into it i need to find a
way to scrape it off my shoe
so i think like what happens with sports
and it's difficult for us to comprehend
because
we feel like we root for you know
especially if you're a saints fan but if
you're an nfl fan you've been watching
rooting uh drew brees has been part of
your life for almost two decades now so
you feel like you know this guy you
don't know him you do not know drew
brees but his teammates know him his
teammates know him on an intimate level
his teammates know him in that locker
room there's something about a locker
room being with your teammates when the
camera when the cameras are off brooker
mcfarlane came on part of my take today
made this this point that when the
phones are off and the cameras are off
and you're just there with your
teammates it's just a different
conversation it's a different vibe so i
agree with you that you would i would
like to see drew understand what he said
is uh off he's off the mark but i also
completely understand that his teammates
can have that uh about face pretty
quickly because they know drew brees
they know what type of guy he is they've
they've been in the trenches with him
they have a relationship with him
where it's just different so we get
caught in this spot as fans we think we
know these guys and we think we know
everything about them so when they say
something stupid or they say something
great we're like oh well that's the guy
for the right you know we cast that die
and we say that's that's drew brees
forever
the the guys in that locker room know
drew brees so i'm not surprised that
they're able to bend that fence
uh fairly quickly because there's an
established relationship there
through years and years of struggling
together so i i'm not surprised by that
part and i have no problem i mean if
that's how his teammates feel that's how
they feel and i believe it i i do think
it's sincere i don't think michael
thomas is being held you know to be like
hey
no one called michael thomas said hey
let's make this right i think drew brees
called michael thomas and they had a
conversation as friends as teammates
with an established relationship that we
just don't have with any of these
players
everything you said is spot on but i put
myself in the position of a teammate of
drew brees because we all have
relationships with the people that we
work with and if something like this
happens
look whatever it took to get and we
flashed the various tweets from the
teammates who have accepted publicly the
drew brees apology michael thomas alvin
kamara cam jordan retweeting demario
davis tomorrow davis was actually on cnn
live when the apology first landed he
hadn't even read it when he reacted to
it the first time and accepted it tehran
armstead has accepted it that's fine but
if i'm one of his teammates again if i
was upset by what he said if i disagree
vehemently with his view
at some point during that interaction
big head i'm going to say to drew brees
so can we kneel or can we not kneel are
you going to look at us out of the
corner of your eye are you going to
think of us differently if we take a
knee during the national anthem or are
you with us
we you i need to understand that and if
you are with us
i i got i got a request for you drew i
need you to go tell everybody you're
with us i need i need you to say to the
world as a white prominent quarterback
hey everybody
when these guys decide to take a knee
this year it's not disrespectful to the
flag it's not
it is engaging in peaceful protest aimed
at reiterating the message that colin
kaepernick was trying to bring us all
to understand four years ago before he
was shoved out of the league in part
because of the fact that he let all the
players realize that you have this right
you have this power and feel free to use
it i want to know where drew stands and
i want him to tell the world where he
stands if i'm one of his teammates and i
think that's a fair request that's a
fair request if you're going to put the
toothpaste back in the tube that's the
only way to do it big cat you got to go
out and say i've changed my position i
fully support
any peaceful protest in which my
teammates choose to engage
i i hear you i just think that um
knowing that it's drew brees opinion
i don't think his opinion i mean maybe
it's actually a good thing mike that
doesn't if it doesn't change he's but
big cat if his opinion hasn't changed
he's got nothing to apologize for
there's no apology
hold on that's my point though maybe
it's a good thing that he hasn't come
out and said it 24 hours later because i
don't i don't really believe if someone
just says oh i changed my entire opinion
about this issue in 24 hours maybe he
needs to reflect on it more so he
apologized for the backlash and like you
said doing an interview explaining how
he thinks that like listening to other
people
and understanding their struggle can't
happen overnight so in a weird way drew
brees not coming out and saying oh i
think exactly the opposite today that i
did yesterday i i don't know that would
if he did that it would ring hollow
would you not say that would you not no
no it would not know
no it rings no no big cat it rings
hollow when you say i apologize
but you don't say
and you don't change the thing
that you that you apologize for i mean
i'm trying to think of a good example
here um
it's it's like you're walking down the
street with some sort of a of an
offensive message on your shirt and you
walk down the street all day long with a
message that offends people on your
shirt they get offended they get upset
with you
and
you apologize to them
and then the next day you show up and
you're still wearing the shirt that
that's my point he's either he's either
taking the shirt off or he's not
does he is he still wearing that shirt i
never will agree with someone
disrespecting the flag are you still
wearing that shirt if i'm his teammate
that's what i want to know that's what i
want to know as
an american do you do you still wear
that shirt
i think he's taking it off if you want
to use that analogy he's slowly taking
it off and i understand that as human
beings it is hard like
understanding
you know a deeper issue and
understanding how you're wrong here
having a little introspection that i'm
giving drew the benefit of the doubt
here which he probably doesn't even
deserve because it's like hey this was
his opinion yesterday and it's hard to
change your opinion that quickly but i'm
just saying i get his teammates coming
out and saying look we talked personally
we talked man-to-man and i accept his
apology because i know the type of guy
he is and then on top of it i think drew
brees
will hopefully in the next week or so
have a longer discussion about it be
like here's where i was wrong here's how
i now understand this issue and i think
that
feels because because we do see it right
now mike in 2020 where it's
do something wrong apologize right away
rinse and repeat so i'm hoping that that
drew
it's you know he got the apology he did
the double apology which is never good
never a good sign the double apology in
one day
but in a week or so he can express
exactly how he feels now and exactly how
he was wrong maybe i'm wrong but i'll
just give him that that that if his
teammates are saying i accept your
apology that they probably ask them some
hard questions and that drew is going to
to actually explain how his opinion has
shifted in the last week after thinking
about it
i think we may be on the verge of being
able to start our own pr consulting firm
because through this conversation this
is the easy solution in a situation like
this you've got three options
one
i apologize and i have changed my
opinion
two
i apologize that you disagree so
vehemently with my opinion but it
remains my opinion
three
i apologize for
my opinion and the reaction to it will
cause me to spend the next few days
reflecting and praying on my opinion as
to whether or not it is an opinion that
i will continue to adhere to but i think
you got to say one of those three things
you can't come out and apologize and
ignore the thing that sparked the uproar
that caused you to apologize there is a
doughnut hole the doughnut hole is
bigger than the doughnut in this apology
until we know
whether his position is i've changed my
opinion or i'm sorry you disagree with
my opinion or i'm revisiting my opinion
and i'll get back to you on whether or
not i change it
four
never double or double apologize in a 24
hour span because that's always when
you're like hey i i screwed up the first
apology here's another one that that
always uh that always doesn't look so
great and especially you know drewbry
should have done the video to start with
because i think the written apology like
you said he did an interview the first
time he expressed how he felt so match
that expression
with doing an interview the second time
and and answer questions about how your
opinion has changed and really show that
what he needs to do is be part of a
conversation like the one we're having
so we can drill down and get to the
bottom of where he stands is he thinking
and reflecting on whether or not he will
change i will never agree it's got to be
hard to back off of that when you just
said less than 48 hours ago i will never
agree with anyone disrespecting the flag
malcolm jenkins who had some passionate
videos one was deleted then another one
was posted he said nothing publicly
privately according to shaq he's
accepted drew brees apology i have been
checking the malcolm jenkins instagram
and twitter feeds over and over again
because frankly from my perspective i
want to know what he thinks and i don't
want to interpret anything one way or
the other into his silence but i would
have expected to hear from him by now
and we'll be monitoring that uh
throughout the show over the weekend
whenever malcolm jenkins has something
to say
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports